how're you doing today
I'm fine sir how are we good I'm okay
can you tell where I'm from for my
accent Irish Oh nearly English English
for my grandmother's Irish okay you're
all brothers anyway yeah same thing
got your brother's so you know yeah I've
come from England okay and I'm basically
I'm doing a talk show with brother Eddie
I've got a show called the Dean show oh
yeah you heard of it your own 19 is yeah
yeah oh you heard of the shot watch all
night it yeah buddy did you recognize
him yeah you recognize it
so many people know about the Dean show
right yeah you've seen many good
conversations and what do you think of
it
he is very precise let me say that you
know God watch like three four times
yeah but I have seen it he's very
precise and he gets to the point it's
not like you know a lot of times people
explain things they try to confuse you a
little bit and take other directions
yeah but I like it when you stayed to
the point and you explained I suggest to
the ultra pass and there's no it's just
straight to the pond yes I mean I before
I was a Muslim I was a Christian I used
to watch his show uni and it helped me a
lot because it helped me understand that
God is one you know God is separate from
yes yeah yeah yes I was just fine
yourself as well yeah I was just talking
to someone
and they were I was explaining to them
you know the religion hoopla but once
you actually read and study the
different religions we're all brothers
you know I get you know yeah so Jesus is
in the Quran yeah I mean and when you
look at the phone he's talking about the
one true God
yeah and he's talking about all the
prophets sent through time Prophet
Abraham Moses Jesus Mohammed talking
about all the prophets and they all came
with the same message that God is one
yeah and believe in all the prophets I
mean do you believe in one God you can't
imagine go yes I believe in one guy and
you believe Jesus a prophet of God yes
it's not a part of God like either
probably it's been giving the message of
God won't be honest with you real quick
I got a little work but um to be honest
with you as I'm grown now
no growing up I grew up in the Christian
Church grandmother back those things of
that nature and you have a thousand and
one questions yes now that I'm grown and
I read for myself and I look at things
for myself yes I do believe he's a
prophet I'm gonna get shot in the
program but lunch but honestly I believe
he's a prophet I believe the Bible has
wonderful stories is okay but I like the
Quran because it's a realistic view you
don't translate and it makes sense not
ask you to do something and it's not
saying that if you do this you got hit
you know I'm saying it's basically said
in life when you do things there are
actions behind that action yeah
yes true and that's why I like the coin
so why you know I'm listening basic that
I believe in one God yeah you believe
what the quran is saying yeah you
believe the car needs a message from God
yes believe in all the prophets are you
believe in angels yeah is believing that
in paradise you are Muslim and the only
thing is to come into the fold of Islam
is to say that I believe in one God
Allah I bear witness that only God is
worthy of worship and that Muhammad is
the final messenger of Nursing and in
July to savor you can simply say that
today it is just try to convert me hello
tell me it's I mean there's no
compulsion in religion but it's not
about converting you if you already
believe it true you know I'm so true you
already believe that this is just
acknowledging what you believe yes so me
it's just to say that you believe you
bare witness that there's nothing worthy
of worship except the praise of God
idiot I agree and Muhammad is the final
messenger and Jesus is a messenger and
Abram is message on yes
yeah leaving it yes so there's some I
bear witness I bear witness that there's
nothing worthy of worship they've got
the worthy of worship except God Allah
God Allah
Mohammed is the final machine at the
trial investiture and we're going to do
it in Arabic you can repeat after me
okay this ashadu ashadu anna anna anna
anna la la ilaha illa illa Allah and
Allah is ill Allah Allah wah wah
ashadu ashadu anna anna muhammadan
mohammed rasoolullah soon rustle rustle
rustle rustle rustle Allah Allah I said
Young's I mean this is simple as that
your even loan is what you already
believe yes I'm not conveying you yes
Allah is guided yes I was a Christian
before in later tell me Jesus God is the
son of Allah this is that Jesus never
said this Jesus was worshiping what yes
this helped me just acknowledging the
truth yes so humble are you Muslim so
how long have you been watching the Deen
show I think I've seen about 3-4 times
that's why I say so tell 19 not that's
how I know I like people with positive
messages yeah you know the world is so
there's so much going on there so when
we reached out to look into the car
Oh God about five years ago and my
mother
you got a Quran in your house you know
and I was like it's the word from God
see no ideas you've knew that he's a
word from God yes and he's took me five
years son yes are you happy now that
you've acknowledged that you are Muslim
I am happy do you have any Muslim
friends yes so are you gonna tell them
yeah get on the phone hello
yeah see I've just become almost look
yeah and they can teach you more they
can teach you a lot more oh yeah indeed
I'm so happy for your sister
thank you